get ready to party because we have the
strangest dance scene since Pulp Fiction
I've ever seen Tim Burton's new series
Wednesday based off The Adams Family is
a rip roaring good time which will have
you saying this is my costume I'm a
homicidal maniac I know that didn't make
any sense but I just wanted to put the
clip in there be sure to like And
subscribe and join me as we take a deep
dive into season one and The Season's
biggest Cliffhangers be afraid be very
afraid Wednesday's first season is a
murder mystery several murders to be
exact it seems as soon as Wednesday
Adams shows up to Nevermore Academy as
school for outcasts bodies keep piling
up now what's worth mentioning that
Nevermore Academy isn't your typical
School founded in 1791 the school is
broken down into four main cliques the
fangs vampires The Furs werewolves
Stoners Stone turning Gorgons and scales
Sirens based off of Greek mythology
Wednesday however doesn't fall into any
of these categories she herself is an
outcast at a school for outcasts but as
we'll see later Wednesday possesses
Supernatural powers and these Powers
help her get to the bottom of
nevermore's murderous Monster by The
Season's final episode Wednesday is sure
she has found the killer a fellow
student Xavier Thorpe who she believes
transforms into a monster known as a
hide she's found him near the scene of
several of the murders and he has a
weird compulsion to draw the very
monster she claims him to be but hides
don't work alone in fact they're
controlled by a master after finding
Xavier secretly meeting with Town
therapist Dr kinbot she believes him to
be controlled by her and has Xavier
arrested but as we'll soon find out
Xavier isn't the killer at all in the
season's second last episode Wednesday
tells Tyler Galpin the sheriff's son and
local Barista that she's solved the case
and the two's ongoing will they won't
they sexual tension culminates in a kiss
this is a big step for Wednesday who
sees emotion as weakness hugsley emotion
equals weakness Zay Xavier even calls
her out for it let's be honest emotion
isn't exactly your strong suit but
Wednesday has built up feelings for
Tyler and lets her emotions take over
and ironically enough this is what
allows her to pinpoint him as the real
killer throughout the season Wednesday
has experienced Visions both of the past
and present this is a supernatural
ability her mother Morticia also
possessed but even by the end of the
season Wednesday isn't sure what
triggers them learning to harness this
Powers will undoubtedly be something
she'll need to cultivate especially if
she's going to survive in the dangerous
world of Nevermore and surrounding town
of Jericho with Tyler surrounded
Wednesday and other members of The
Nightshade Society a secret elite club
vowing to protect Nevermore tie him up
in Xavier's shed and confront him thing
Wednesday's one-handed companion stole
Tyler's Dead Mother's medical records
where they learned his mother was a hide
as well as passed on this ability to him
Wednesday knows the only way to get at a
hide through pain but none of her
friends have what it takes to torture
him and end up abandoning her even going
so far as to turn her into the cops at
the station Tyler is let go his dad is
the sheriff and there's no evidence to
suggest he's the killer in exchange for
them not pressing charges against
Wednesday or the school Wednesday is to
be expelled from Nevermore for good and
it gets worse when Tyler and Wednesday
are alone he Reveals His Sinister secret
that he is indeed the monster what does
it feel like
what does what feel like
to lose he's the bad guy right using
thing to distract the guards Wednesday
goes to Xavier who is still on the hook
for the murders and he can't be too
happy to see her the girl who put him
there she tells him that she was wrong
and that the real murderer is Tyler and
maybe Xavier can help he has some sort
of weird psychic connection with Tyler
but Xavier isn't having any of it every
time you get involved people get hurt
all you ever do is make things worse
Xavier's words Pierce her like a dagger
maybe he's right maybe the best thing
for Nevermore is for her not to be there
she packs up her things says goodbye to
her roomie Enid and is about to head
home when she hears her friend Eugene
odinger has awoken from his coma in the
hospital Eugene was one of Wednesday's
first friends at Nevermore and the two
are the only members of the Nevermore
Hummers a beekeeping Society Eugene went
by himself in search of the monster and
found someone blowing up the monster's
Den before he was viciously attacked he
tells Wednesday that the person who
perpetrated this had unique red boots
and if you go all the way back to
episode 1 you'll see this clue of Miss
thornhill's muddy red boots Miss
Thornhill is played by Christina Ricci
who played Wednesday in the 1990 films
so Wednesday decides to confront the
real monster controlling Tyler her
teacher Miss Thornhill but as Wednesday
theorizes Miss Thornhill isn't her real
name she's actually Laurel Gates a
daughter of notorious Outcast hater on
Soul Gates you see the gates in Adam's
family have beef going back hundreds of
years in the early 1600s the town of
Jericho was led by a pilgrim named
Joseph crackstone an ancestor of the
gates family he ordered all outcasts or
those he thought had Supernatural Powers
burned one of these outcasts was a goody
Adams a distant ancestor of Wednesdays
goody would go on to create The
Nightshade Society to protect her kind
from crack Stone's oppression a few
hundred years later the battle between
crackstone and the outcast wages on
Ansel Gates Furious that the outcasts
have built a school on what he believes
to be their land orders his son Garrett
to infiltrate the Nevermore dance and
Spike the punch with poison but as we
see in one of Wednesday's Visions while
Gomez fights Garrett who apparently has
a crush on Morticia the vial of poison
breaks and infects him turning him into
a blind rage Garrett's death at the
hands of Morticia was covered up his
father drank himself to death mother
hung herself and sister went overseas
where it was said she drowned but she
never drowned at all as it turns out
this sister Laurel Gates took on a
pseudonym Teresa L Glau which if you
rearrange the letters spells out Laurel
gates the gates Mansion was purchased by
a 90 year old candy heiress who
mysteriously died and gave the place to
her caregiver one Teresa Glau Teresa
then switched her name yet again to miss
Thornhill and got a job at Nevermore but
Laurel's master plan is far from
reaching fruition as we'll see later on
Laurel wants to resurrect Joseph
crackstone himself to rain fire on the
outcasts and Avenger family once and for
all but first Wednesday shows offer
detective skills by revealing Laurel's
plan she used a chemical made from her
plants to unlock the monster within
Tyler she would have known Tyler is a
hide because her father kept tabs on all
the monsters in town and Tyler's mom was
known to be one by manipulating Tyler
she eventually became his master as we
we learn in episode 7 from Nathaniel
Faulkner's journal the founder of
Nevermore obsessed with outcasts and
monsters that hides develop a bond with
whomever releases them this app caused
Society to develop an immediate bond
with its Liberator the creature now sees
its Master by becoming Tyler's Master
Laura was able to carry out gruesome
attacks against any of her enemies
including Dr kimbot Who came too close
to discovering the truth about Tyler and
guess who happens to show up during this
confrontation none other than Tyler who
Laurel instructs to kill Wednesday but
surprise surprise it isn't Tyler at all
but none other than principal Weems who
has shape-shifted earlier in the season
Wednesday discovered by going through an
old yearbook that principal Weems could
shape-shift and she used this
opportunity to bring the principal
herself to Laurel's confession
unfortunately for principal Weems she's
poisoned by Laurel and Wednesday is
knocked out now you might be asking
yourself how come Laurel doesn't just
kill Wednesday right here that's because
she still needs her for her master plan
resurrecting Joseph crackstone when
Wednesday awakens she finds herself
chained in crack Stone's tomb on Raven
Island there Laurel has begun a Magic
Ritual containing various body parts of
Tyler's victims only by using these
items on the night of a Blood Moon and
combining them with the blood of an
Adam's family member the family line
that killed crack Stone Those hundreds
of years ago can Joseph be resurrected
this is why goody Adams in a vision to
Wednesday warns her that she is the key
Laurel slashes Wednesday's palm and the
blood reacts to the tomb Joseph
crackstone is resurrected to seek his
revenge on the outcasts and of course
first is Wednesday who he thinks is
goody he makes quick work of her
stabbing her in the stomach as he and
Laurel make their way to Nevermore
meanwhile Eugene calls Enid to let them
know he hasn't heard from Wednesday or
principal Weems since they went on to
confront Laurel prompting Enid and the
Gang to assemble The Nightshade Society
to warn Nevermore that trouble is on the
way and the perfect way to do this is
through the sirens who use their power
of manipulation to get the staff and
students out of the building as she Lay
Dying Wednesday is visited by the spirit
of goody goody tells her the only way to
kill crack stone is to stab him directly
in his black heart but there's one
problem is your spectral vision impaired
I'm dying in episode 1 you'll remember
Morticia gave Wednesday an obsidian
necklace one with a special connection
to the spirit world goodie uses this
Talisman to pass through Wednesday and
heal her with a deadly leprechaun
looking Pilgrim on its way to Nevermore
Wednesday rushes back to the academy but
is stopped by Tyler he turns into hide
about to kill Wednesday when she's saved
by Enid in werewolf form throughout the
season Enid has been self-conscious
about her inability to turn into one it
seems every one of her friends and
family has the ability to do it but all
she can muster are these elongated claws
but on the night of a blood moon when
her friend needs her most Ian it
transforms into to a werewolf and takes
on the hide eventually stopping Tyler
and putting him in custody in fact it's
Tyler's own dad who shoots him and takes
him in that's gonna be an awkward
Thanksgiving back at Nevermore Wednesday
prepares for the final showdown and
grabs the same sword her father used to
take on Garrett Gates 32 years ago but
it soon becomes apparent that crack
Stone's skills are not of this world he
stops Xavier's Arrow midair you may
remember Xavier showing off his bow
skills earlier in the season he escaped
from the sheriff's cop car with the help
of thing Wednesday who once lamented
that friends are a weakness actually
steps in front of the arrow and saves
Xavier from being shot it mirrors her
life being saved by him in episode 1.
it's also a nice way to apologize for
falsely accusing him of murder and
sending him to jail crackstone and
Wednesday duke it out where we get to
see Wednesday's fencing skills put to
the test alas she is no match for her
Pilgrim Foe and it's only when Bianca
comes to the rescue that Wednesday is
able to use this distraction and stab
him through his black heart he
disintegrates leaving behind only his
ring I thought it was pretty interesting
that they did a close-up of this ring
was this just a fun shot they wanted to
add or could it be used in the future to
potentially bring him back speaking of
bringing someone back there's good old
Laurel who's none too pleased that her
grand plan has fallen to Hell literally
she may not have been able to kill all
the outcasts but at least she'll be able
to kill Wednesday and in a shocking turn
of events a bunch of bees come to save
the day
yes Eugene is able to harness the power
of the bees to incapacitate Laurel and
this is the last we see of her we can
assume she'll be arrested but no word if
she'll make a return in any future
Seasons outside the courtyard Enid and
Wednesday have their first hug
throughout the season Wednesday has
shied away from hugging but here she
instigates it showing just how far she's
come along as a character and just as
the season comes to an end so too does
Wednesday's book she's been writing this
story of a young girl named Viper de la
Muir day and her overbearing mother a
story which mimics her real life the
question mark after the end is also a
question on whether or not the show will
get a season two Wednesday also says
goodbye to Xavier all charges have been
dropped and the two seem friends again
she did take an arrow for him after all
to show his appreciation he's given her
a cell phone so they can stay in touch
over the break no doubt the relationship
between Wednesday and Xavier will be
explored next season especially with
Tyler out of the pitcher well kinda the
last shot of the season is him
transforming back into the hide as he's
escorted away I personally think it
would be pretty cheap if he escaped here
they know he's a hide and he's supposed
to be chained up so that even if he did
transform he wouldn't be able to escape
similar to how Xavier was chained up in
the police station when they thought he
was a hive what I do think will come
into play next season is this mysterious
text Wednesday receives on her phone
Wednesday believes it to be a stalker
who has been taking photos of her
throughout the season so we can probably
rule out Xavier and Tyler here if I were
to take a guess on who it is my money
would be on either someone we haven't
met yet or Bianca Bianca is the only one
who has a real motive to stalk Wednesday
when she's with these other boys
remember that Bianca and Xavier used to
date so she may be jealous of Wednesday
and this budding connection Bianca's
family also makes phone apps that
indoctrinate its users so I wonder if
that will come into play at all but who
do you think the mysterious stalker is I
want to hear your thoughts and theories
and what you thought of the season in
the comments below thanks for watching
be sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember is your
spectral vision impaired I'm dying
foreign